let's get started on today's science
technology and energy committee
continuation of an exec session
before we start i'd like you all to
rise and join me in a moment of silence
for the people who have died in ukraine
and now remain standing while
representative berezni leads us in the
pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance
thank you
before we start our
regularly scheduled business today
which will be comprised of
a continuation of an exec session on
house bill
followed by a presentation by the
eversource arborist but before we start
uh that activity
i'd like to just go over a couple of
things that everybody here should be
aware of we have a house session
on thursday march 10th
and the leadership team has the
speaker's office has requested that you
reserve
tuesday
the 15th wednesday the 16th and thursday
the 17th
for house sessions
apparently they're not 100 sure that
we're going to be here all three days
but they would like you to reserve those
three days just in case
none of our bills
are being brought up this coming
thursday so all 20 of the bills that
we've exact or will have exec by the end
of today
will be
heard on either tuesday wednesday or
thursday of next week i don't know how
they plan to spread things out
i do know in the past
that when we've had a lot of bills
at the end of the march session they
have tried to
reverse things
on one or more days so that st e
wouldn't always be last sometimes we'd
be first
or close to the beginning of the session
so hopefully that will happen
but there's no guarantee
but i just wanted you to be aware of of
what the schedule looks like
representative thomas thank you mr chair
i did happen to approach that question
with the speaker's office last week and
at this point they have they have no
plans to do any reversal of
of the calendar
they'll keep to the schedule as it
always has been i guess
so
and i have one further question mr uh
will we will we be having any other
committee meetings here before the 29th
of the month
do you know
that's tbd
i did talk to the clerk he said that
we could start hearing senate bills even
before crossover
provided that the senate sends them to
us
so if they do that it's there is the
potential we may have a session before
the 29th but
as of today i don't know of one so
if we do it it'll be on a monday or a
tuesday follow-up uh yeah so if if i
made just a general announcement
everyone here has been contacted but we
we will be having a
field trip to the seabrook station
everybody in this room right now has
responded to me so that's good
and those that have said that they would
be
attending please watch your emails for
future emails on the details times and
information you'll have to provide and
so forth
thank you representative occident
thank you mr chair
has there been any explanation of why
none of our bills will be heard this
week because this means that everything
will be jammed and we will have the
maximum pressure to
table everything and forego proper
consideration of the work that's done by
the members of this committee
well i have already expressed my concern
to leadership that
we've been tabling far too many of our
bills so they're aware of our concern
about that
the reason that none of our bills were
scheduled for this coming session on
thursday is because we didn't get them
done on time and i'll take full
responsibility for that i shouldn't have
waited until the end to do all the exact
sessions we should have been doing exec
sessions concurrently with our public
hearings
that was a
sort of a rookie mistake on my part
so i will take full responsibility for
that and apologize to all of you for
doing that we won't make that mistake
again when we start receiving senate
bills we'll have public hearings and
exec sessions
one after the other
maybe not right after a public hearing
but maybe the next day
so that we make sure we get all these
bills adjudicated
before
the end of the
of the time period before the deadline
representative callie pitts
is that going to give us time to discuss
the bills if we're going to do them so
quickly
i i don't know what's coming up but i
know some things require discussion
so i want to be sure that we're going to
be able to do that
that's a good point what we're going to
do
is at the conclusion of every public
hearing we're going to discuss
what the next step will be do you want
to go directly to exec session or do you
want to have a work session
what is your pleasure and we'll decide
that as a committee and then we'll
move forward with whatever that decision
is
representative notter thank you mr
chairman you don't have to apologize for
not having all the bills done early
because every committee is different if
you look at some of the other committees
they do the same thing and that's why
once a year in march we have a very busy
week with sometimes uh three days in a
row of session or
last term we had that overnight session
so if you you haven't been a
representative until you have um
survived a slumber party in reps hall
that's a good point
i take a lot of pride in in running an
efficient committee and so that's why i
apologize because i feel i let
myself and the rest of the committee
down by not being quite as efficient as
we could have been it wasn't really a
mistake just a
a
less than efficient process and i'll
address that with my performance going
forward
representative platt
just a reminiscent of last term when we
met all night long i was scintillating
at four in the morning with a floor
speech
that's true you were you are
this is
scintillating scintillating fred that's
what we call him
so it it appears now that we have a
substitute today for
representative
mick williams i believe it is
hi mr chair representative schultz
representative schultz is substituting
for
representative mick williams welcome
representative schultz we're glad to
have you here today it's an honor to be
with you thank you you're welcome thank
you
all right any uh further questions or
representative oxenoum
perhaps this is a point of order or
point of clarification
i noticed that the amendment that we
were are about to be considering has
numerous uh typographical and other
confusing material
are we
going to do something about that and
have yet another
well we're going to discuss any
discrepancies that you find in the bill
we have discovered a couple ourselves
and they are the type of typos that
would be corrected by ols during the
bill enrollment process
so we're not going to do anything about
those
unless somebody finds something that is
egregious and is not a typo that would
have to be addressed so that will happen
during our discussion of the amendment
once we get there
anything else
okay
let's resume the executive session on
house bill
1469 and i recognize representative
platt yes mr chair we passed 2022-037-h
on the 28th so i now make a motion to
reconsider that vote
a second
it's been moved and seconded that we
reconsider the vote on house bill 1459
and i would like to know if there's any
discussion on that motion
i i will just say
that uh
when this bill was drafted
it started out with the manufacturer
being the responsible party and people
raised the objection what if it's
chinese how you go chase them so then it
was suggested we make it retailer and
then
we got some feedback well what if the
retailers in mexico so now it's the
installer they're always local
okay well we can debate
the
merits of the amendment in just a minute
but first we have to
get rid of the old amendment so
seeing
that there is no further discussion on
the motion to reconsider
i would
urge everyone to vote yes on
reconsideration and ask the clerk to
call the role thank you mr chair
representative thomas yes representative
harrington
yes representative notter yes
representative berner
he's not here i didn't mark that sorry
a rep
representative plett votes yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes represent
cambrils yes representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
lewicki yes represent some sitch is here
okay
where is that thing
representative callie pitts has stepped
out of the room oh okay you're here
thank you represent man yes
representative luxem yes representative
vincent
not here okay
represent mcgee
yes
represent
representative schultz
yes rep
represent creatures not here uh
representative pimentel
representative partial
and the chair yes
four absence seventeen four
so by a vote of seventeen uh wait a
second not four absolutely that's not
that can't make seven
huh
four five six seven eight through
campbell's
12 13 14 15 16 17
18 and that's what i have 18
uh four and four missing
okay so
uh 18 having voted yey
zero nays
the motion passes mr chair
uh representative representative platt
is recognized i i
i moved to re-adopt the amendment we
just reconsidered and hope you vote no
any discussion on this question
representative plett has
moved that we re-adopt the previous
amendment the number of which i don't
have right in front of me
both 337h
and everybody is requested to vote no on
that
uh amendment
so representative please call the roll
yes okay
representative thomas
no representative harrington no
representative notter no representative
murder not here i wish i knew some of
this in advance to fix this thing uh
representative platt votes now
representative berezni no representative
bernardi no representative campbell's no
represent pleasure no representative
white no representative lewicki no
represents not here
i represent cali pets
represent cali pitts
represent man
no
representative no
representative mcgee no
now this thing is messed up see if i can
make it work anyway
representative vince is not here
represent williams
um hold on schultz yeah hold on one
second
now
representative questions not here
representative pimentel
representative partial
in the chair
yeah uh no
did i cut represent did i call you
i honestly can't remember
your vote is no thank you
so
this thing is screwed up
so this is again 18 this is
yeah he did folk so if this is 0 18 4.
okay by a vote of 18 yay zero nay
no by a vote of zero yay and 18 days
the
amendment is not adopted so the original
bill is on the floor open for further
amendment i recognize representative
platt yes and i'll pass out the
amendment
take one yourself and pass this away
mr chair i
moved to adopt the amendment uh to hb
1459 fn the amendment number is
2022-0940
i'll second that
representative platt moves and
representative harrington seconds the
adoption of amendment 0940h
and we can now discuss
this amendment
i'll recognize representative platt
first
as i said earlier this this wording is
the same except for a couple of typos
the correct krypton will get fixed but
i'll ask people to
point out what they think is a typo
but it changes the onus it puts the onus
on the installer who should be
either
local or a surrounding state at worst
okay
okay further discussion on this
representative mcgee yes thank you mr
chairman um fred it puts the onness on
the installer but it also puts the
expense
on the installer
i'm referring specifically to section
three on page two that says the
stewardship plan shall at a minimum
describe how installers will finance the
take back and recycling system including
an adequate funding mechanism to finance
the costs of collection management and
recycling of photovoltaic voltaic
modules
and residuals sold in or into the state
by the installer with the mechanism that
ensures that photovoltaic modules can be
delivered to take back locations without
cost to the last owner or holder and the
question that i have for you
representative flatt
is why wouldn't the
why wouldn't the cost of that recycling
be on
the the person who owns the system like
because to me it they're the owner and
it could be 20 25 years you don't know
if these companies
are going to be around and so it's very
hard to structure it the way you have it
structured and make it work
you follow where you were but i heard
your words so
representative platt is recognized sorry
yeah it's section three on page two
lines okay 19 through 26. the answer is
obviously it will be on the owner
because uh the installer is an
out-of-pocket cost they're going to pass
that on to the owner or they're going to
get some
uh some contributions from the installer
or
the the retailer or manufacturer but
it's going to be paid for and and that
cost will be passed on to the owner it
may be a discounted cost because you're
collecting money now for 25 years from
now and so it's a fun to grow but it
will be passed under the owner one way
or the other
up follow up that can get
very complicated the way that you just
described that um
and i think that that to me is the crux
of what
would be
not responsible about putting this in
without further information on how this
would actually be enacted because
what it does is it puts the onus on the
installer and says you're going to have
to figure out a way
to
finance this and put money aside for it
and prove that you're doing that but it
doesn't really talk about
in any specific way about the
implementation which because of the long
time differential seems like it
it's very hard to make happen i just i
don't understand how this bill can be
implemented
and to me it looks like a real
disincentive because it's going to add
costs
to the installers
bottom line
for a service that i thought we were
trying to incent in the state
so representative mcgee if you look at
page two lines five six
yep etc
it just directs the department of
environmental services to develop
guidance for the model stewardship and
take back program so the installers
won't be
tasked with creating the program
themselves they'll get guidance from des
on how to create the program
and presumably des would come up with a
guide that every in style installer
would would follow to create those
programs and that seems inconsistent as
well because it says by january 2024 the
department shall have established the
process but it's asking the installers
as of july of 2022 to begin creating
programs that would be governed by
guidelines that don't exist until you
know a year and a half later
i believe if you look at lines 20
on line 20 on page 2 it specifies july
1st of 2030
not 2022 i'm sorry where am i looking
here oh it's down except all of their
it's line 27 i'm looking at except all
of their photovoltaic model modules sold
in or into the state jul by after july
so that's the date i was looking at
and that's the section on stewardship
plan right representative platt
thank you mr chair i don't know who the
who who who
is trying to incent solar
i'm neutral uh frankly i'm not trying to
incent anything nor am i trying to
disincent i'm trying to reflect the true
cost
and and recover it so it doesn't wind up
worse than landfills in the in the woods
like tires do
i'll just leave it there
okay further discussion representative
mann has a comment
yeah i think this
i i
don't usually like to think of myself as
negative but i really don't like this
bill at all i think it adds cost to the
and disincense of solar installations
which we really need to do
for climate reasons
which are far exceed anything about
dumps
in landfills um
and i i would
think that the bill would at least first
investigate the whole issue of recycling
and require in other words require
or set up
a process or procedure or responsibility
for investigating the whole issue of
of recycling and this bill just assumes
that
we don't know but we know who's going to
pay for it
and
i think it's just
has a very bad effect on
what we really need to be getting done
thank you
thank you before i take another comment
i want to point out that on page 3
line 22
and line 32
repeat the word installer
so it says a distributor installer or
installer
that's the typo that ols will fix
when if the ball
if the bill gets to the enrollment
process
so please let me know if there are any
others
representative
oxenom thank you mr chair there are
about seven different ones where it says
a installer and it should say an
installer there are three
installer or installer references and i
can hand you a an edited version
um
that wasn't the reason i had my hands up
however am i am i called on for a
content um
yes let me just point out that for
example on line 30 on page three it says
a installer we probably should say an
installer that's the kind of typo that
ols would fix yes so we don't have to
worry about that but now you're
recognized to make other comments about
the uh
amendment
that this particular bill does go
against stated state policy in our
10-year strategic plan and also in our
statutes in which we do incentivize
renewable energy because the state does
recognize that renewable energy is in
fact of value to the state its citizens
and its businesses i don't know why we
want to disincentivize a local business
which provides local jobs local
opportunities i don't know why we would
want to engage in mandating
a a policy which has a punitive fine
attached to it this appears to be a
problem insert
a solution excuse me in search of a
problem where we're drowning in plastic
bags we have ocean animals that are
stranded on beaches that is a problem
that needs addressing
tires were a problem as representative
pointed out and that has been addressed
no other single industry in new
hampshire has been singled out in the
fashion of this bill and i think that's
a very bad idea it puts a burden on our
local businesses and as much as i am in
favor of
extended producer responsibility
that is the way to go redesign the
product so it minimizes the waste
but we don't do that in this way and as
a final point not only are our
installers having to pay for the
things that are mentioned on page two
but on page four
i believe it's page four yes page four
they're also funding the department of
energy uh you know with this um
taking care of these costs so i i on all
these matters i find this
if you look at roman numeral eight
and you get about several sentences down
it says
uh okay
maybe it's
further down there's hereby actually
lines one and two on page four say the
department may collect a flat fee from
participating installers to recover
costs associated with the plan guidance
review et cetera and it goes on there's
there are many things in here that are
cost for the department that uh the
installers are now going to have to pay
uh and they're sufficiently vague that i
can see other costs also being
put on their back
uh representative platt i just point out
it's not the department of energy it's
the department of environmental services
whichever it's a state department and
it's administrative costs that would not
be burdensome for any other industry but
only this one
representative
oxendium would you see this as being any
different than the costs imposed on
utilities
when they
visit the site evaluation committee to
submit a project to the committee for
consideration
we will have an opportunity to talk
about the site evaluation committee and
there are the short answer is no and you
probably don't want the long answer
today
okay thank you i would argue that it is
very similar representative thomas
thank you mr chair
i think
this is a
bill that has great foresight
we know that there will be a problem we
know there is a problem because we know
that because
we have some some issues now but we know
in the long run
it's going to be a bigger problem
why not
try to come up with a solution
that helps a problem that we know about
instead of you know the old proverbial
kicking the can down the road
it
kind of
surprised me that if it's a
project that someone is not interested
in then they're okay with things but if
it's a project that they are interested
in it's not okay with things i think we
should attack
any problem we see having to do with the
recycling and landfills whether or not
it's our favorite project or not
so i believe this bill
was fashioned after a state a
very very environmentally conscious
state i if i do say so and i would like
to hear from from the sponsor
how a bill of this type has been
accepted and how it's been working in in
the state that this bill was fashioned
after
my understanding it's the state of
washington and my understanding it was
working quite well as originally drafted
manufacturer
so the changes we made would make it
even better uh and
washington state is not alone i mean
california has rules not not law but
rules to do the same thing and there's
several other states who are in
investigating this to eventually do the
same thing including as i recall from my
testimony rhode island
and a few others
any follow-up representative thomas
um well
just that uh if if a problem exists a
problem exists whether it's a
whether it involves an industry that
we're in favor of or an industry that
we're not in favor of i think if the
problem exists we should have the
foresight to try and do something about
it up front even it may take time to
perfect it but i think now is the time
to have the conversation so i'm i'm in
favor of the spill in one form or
another to get the conversation going i
think it's an issue that we need to
address and we right now we have time to
perfect it uh we don't have time when
someone says we should have done this
ten years ago so i'd be in favor of this
bill
thank you representative plett you said
that washington state has rules to
implement this program
doesn't the bill on page 4 line 23
call for the department to adopt rules
for the administration of the
subdivision
well i didn't say that washington state
has rules i said washington state has a
law
that this was modeled after but in that
large it refers to the their equivalent
department developing rules as as does
this one i said california has rules
my mistake thank you
okay further discussion
representative partial
yes i would love to be correct uh
correction to fight this oh thank you
chair i'd love to be corrected if i'm
mistaken but i believe washington state
their
implementation of solar recycling is
done
as part of a comprehensive plan
of
of producer
responsibility which uh
incorporates a number of different uh
uh recycling areas including the solar
panels um
and it does not single out solar panels
per se
i know there is a bill out there that
does single it out but i think they're
attacking the problem in a in a
comprehensive way which i would prefer
because i don't see a lot of solar
panels in our woods but i do see
a lot of tires in our woods
representative platt yes i address this
in my testimony um a lot of the small
stuff tires is
there's a program
at dpw
dtw's transfer stations to pick this
stuff up at reasonable cost i just
supposed to dispose of the computer i
was using here for five bucks
and so it's not big out of pocket cost
tires
aren't that expensive but there were
still some scarf laws that dump them in
the woods i also said that the reason
the solar panels are being picked out is
because a lot of other technologies go
to the site evaluation committee and the
site evaluation committee requires
end of life disposal of some sort
certainly a nuclear plant but win wind
turbines have to have a disposal plan as
well
but
these solar panels are smaller bigger
than the local electronics but smaller
than that scale so that's why this is if
you call it singled out it's it's
something that needs to be fixed and
frankly when we start getting making
progress with this i might come back
someday and say for
power batteries that might be need a
program as well but that's that's
something for a future day
representative callie pitts
i want to thank
representative plett for bringing this
to us
however
i think when this came in
well when this came to us
there was
not the urgency i think that we feel now
this bill was conceived before this
current situation
we are in a situation now where
all kinds of fuel
are going to be in short supply
electricity being one
we don't want to put any more of a
burden on the people who are installing
or the people who are buying
these panels
the average life of a panel is about 30
years and it starts to deteriorate
somewhere around 20. we only really
began
doing
serious work
in the 2000s
i think this bill is worthwhile
i think we have to plan for facilities
to recycle this because transporting
this material to a recycling center
is one in chicago takes care of the
midwest in illinois and say chicago and
illinois a big one and it does all kinds
of electronics including panels there's
a lot to be gained from doing this but i
think the timing
like everything else
is not right right now
and i think this is worthy subject
i think maybe in the next six months
next year
we should be looking at it we should all
be thinking about it and thinking about
where we can put
these recycling plants and thinking
about the actual cost
of what it's really going to be
to recycle materials
it's not easy to send a ship over to
africa anymore or to india
we have to do it right here and we have
to plan to do that and i think that's
that's what we need to do and this bill
right now would put an additional burden
nuclear had a plan because
nobody knew what to do with nuclear fuel
and and it it there's quite a bit of
money in there for decommissioning
but now we know we have another 30 years
so i i just
i just think that the bill is worthy
but not now
this is not the time to put a hammer on
an industry that we hope will grow and
grow even more and if it does then we
have 30 years to take care of the
problem
representative pimentel
thank you mr chairman um
yeah i agree this is a problem that we
need to solve
but we do not need to solve it now
uh
we we have
this
subject deserves to be in a study
committee
so that we can look at it more deeply
come out
solutions i personally think the
solution
is going to be
at the federal level not at the state
level
and uh i i would recommend getting a
hold of our
uh state representative our
representatives in washington and uh let
them know that this is an important
subject
what i don't like about it is that it is
uh
it is
directed only at solar panels there are
so many other uh
things that we need to recycle which are
just as dangerous we also don't know
what
the expense is going to be for recycling
30 years from now
i suspect that instead of costing us
money there may be value in those panels
and so what do we do now should we start
paying the installers for
installing a product that's going to be
worth some money at the end of their
life i don't think so so why don't we
just look into this a little bit more
to
determine what the real costs are going
to be
and
i suppose you could call it kicking it
down the road but i don't think we're
ready for this i think it's a bad bill
at the wrong time
thank you representative mann
thank you mr chairman yeah i have the
same opinion i also feel that
as a previous representative
i also feel that with a little time we
might have some idea about what
the implications are perhaps
a lot of these panels will be moved and
used in other
facilities maybe we'd take our panels
off every 10 years and
some farmer would have
a growing wall on his
on his barn that
is full of old panels i mean it's just
the whole problem is we're not
understood
you don't know what the problem looks
like you don't know how it how things
will work out you don't know what kind
of solutions will be available in the 20
to 30 year time frame we have apparently
thank you representative oxenam had her
hand up first
thank you mr chair i i've handed out a
hand up before the beginning of this
meeting which is an advertisement from
one particular company that is called we
recycle solar they have a nationwide
service they handle every need from pv
panels to energy storage blah blah blah
because this is a profitable industry
with financial return i don't see the
reason for the state to be sticking its
nose in here i don't see the reason for
a mandate and i think that if if if we
don't itl the bill i think i i would
support my fellow representatives who
suggest interim study
thank you representative bernardi is
recognized
thank you mr chairman
i'm going to take a contrary point of
view i think it is time for us to take a
stand on
moving these kinds of programs forward i
think as representative plett has
mentioned this is a
this is a
initial
stand on an issue which we shouldn't be
kicking down the road it can be built
upon for dealing with battery issues
which are also going to
raise a significant problem in the
future or already are in various
landfills or light bulbs containing
mercury or other things which are
difficult to recycle in and difficult to
manage in local landfills we need to
to initiate this kind of a
process this is a good first step we can
make course corrections and additions as
needed
thank you representative partial
yes uh
thank you chair um
to represent kelly pitt's point with
futures market uh petroleum skyrocketing
i'm seeing anything we do right now to
stabilize our energy market is being
critical and that means supporting both
renewable and non-renewable energy um
i see this as a crisis situation and i
don't
want to put the thumb on any particular
industry by saying we're going to
restrict how we're going to produce
energy i think it's
critical
to john mann's point
i solar panels they don't have the
built-in obsolescence from my
observation they don't have that
built-in obsolescence that many of our
products that are cluttered or landfill
have
and even at the end of their life they
still are producing
and they are built
to survive unlike
the printer in my office right now
so by placing your thumb on the local
solar industry i think it's engaging in
bad economics
and making new hampshire less
competitive in regard to other states
i wish we could send this interim study
thank you
representative callie pitts
one of the other things that i think is
really important
is that we should be looking on a
regional level
to establish recycling facilities
i
i don't want i i can't imagine what it's
going to cost
to ship
materials panels computers and what it
costs to send it to chicago or to send
it to washington state or to send it to
arizona when these recycling facilities
are built they don't just recycle one
thing they recycle many things and the
recycling of solar panels in particular
is very important because of what they
can gain from it there is value in that
material
more value than is in
you know we used to say what the human
body was worth now it's worth about 32
cents
um
there's a lot of value in that material
and so
many companies are interested in buying
buying that
so there are many different ways
cities and towns
i believe have to figure out
how to charge for this maybe five
dollars on is unreasonable too little
maybe fifty dollars is too much
maybe added installation cost right now
is a hammer that we don't need
but i think a regional solution
and i think we could instruct very
easily not instruct we could ask
des to look at the situation
and look how much would it cost to have
a regional
recycling facility
for the new england states or maybe
beyond
that would be worth money to the company
that's going to do that
and i i think that
right now
us putting that kind of money
on anybody and i don't know how much it
would cost
we don't know how much it would cost or
add to the installation and right now
people are choking to death and i i'm
going to tell you that from personal
experience
you know um i used to love to take a
ride up to the mountains and just look
at the beauty of this state i don't do
that anymore i ca i don't think i can do
that anymore if gas goes up another 50
cents
you know for some people that's a lot of
money
so the thought of putting in
a solar panel
and having those prices go way up
i think
and we don't know how much right now is
inexpedient i don't want i don't think
this should be killed i think it should
be put into interim study
and i believe that interim study is
truly that
thank you representative thomas thank
you mr chair
i um
probably
i would think i'd like to to uh correct
my good friend from portsmouth i think
due to inflation i think the human body
is probably worth a hundred dollars now
compared to all the inflation we're
having but i would like to state
i would like to state one thing though
if we don't pass this bill now
it is my opinion that this discussion
dies if we pass this bill
we can have further discussion
and we can perhaps come up with perhaps
a better plan but if we don't pass this
bill now the discussion will die i feel
it because people want to kick this can
down the road i think the discussion
needs to be to begin now
uh perhaps a study might come out of it
but we need to pass it in order to have
more discussion
uh
by the next level of our friends so i'm
i'm in favor of voting for this bill
the committee will be in order please
representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman
um i'm just taking in all the all the
comments that have been made and i want
to go back to representative thomas's
comment about this being a visionary
bill
i think we've already discussed several
times that there's a difference of
opinion on the committee about what the
vision should be for energy policy
coming out of this committee
and i would argue that
our solar uptake or our solar
penetration in new hampshire is
extremely low
because we haven't fully supported
the adoption of solar in the state and
that has everything to do with uh the
policies that we put in place and the
objectives that we have
many of us think that the the can that's
been kicked down the road is the warming
of the atmosphere and its effects on
everything else we also have a
difference of opinion about how to go
about creating
the appropriate mix of energy
and so what this bill does though
is it takes an energy source that is a
non-emitting source
that has helped new hampshire have an
energy portfolio diversity
we were trying
15 years ago the discussions were around
increasing our portfolio diversity so
that we didn't have all our eggs in one
basket in gas or oil or coal
and
we've kind of fallen off having any
discussions around what our objectives
are
and we're sort of backpedaling on the
pieces of our portfolio pie that create
that clean diversity that we that was
the objective in the past
so rather than increasing that section
we're adopting policies that take us in
the other direction and make us more
fossil fuel dependent and so i would say
that's the opposite of visionary because
what we're saying is
that it's okay for us to go down the
road of of adopting
more fossil fuel
dependence at a time when the costs
there are going up and i don't think
that that does a service to the people
that we represent because
portfolio diversity was the way we were
keeping our costs down because we were
allowing people to have competition in
the market and options for how they got
their energy
solved so i just want to say that that's
the context in which i view the bill
which is that
when you add costs to something to a
market that's costs have been coming
down in terms of their ability to
compete
then you
move the decisions
in the other direction and i think
that is the can that we do not want to
kick down the road so that's what i have
to say
thank you i'd remind you uh the members
that
one part of the vision is
in my belief and has to be
nuclear energy and we did pass a bill
earlier this session to study
how we can
acquire more
nuclear energy in our state
any further discussion representative
mann yes
thank you mr chairman
um
we're supposed to pay in advance for
recycling when we put the panels up
and my question would be how in the heck
do we know what the recycling costs are
going to be
i mean it seems to me that just to
implement this it really needs to be put
into an interim study so we have some
idea what we're talking about when we
talk about
prepayment
for all of the
recycling
needs
i don't see how that can be escaped
i don't
frankly mr chairman i don't know whether
i'm not familiar i know this is i might
be completely wrong but i'm surprised at
how much you participate in debates
and whether as a chairman that's
appropriate
of course it's appropriate
i'm a member of this legislature i
represent my constituents i'm entitled
to
debate
issues that are relevant to my
constituents
is there any further discussion on this
issue all i'm saying is it's not
familiar to me thank you you're welcome
representative lewicki uh thank you mr
chairman uh i do have questions uh two
points really one of which is i asked
earlier when we were discussing the bill
you know what are the what is the value
of the components and the other thing is
that in a lot of cases what we're doing
is essentially moving pollution to
someplace else we do that with some of
our you know hydro generation we do the
same thing when we're buying things from
china where it's the wild west and um
you know there's no real control over
the environmental issues and um
you know it's a real question and i
believe that it we can put it into
dollars and cents we may be able to
understand it better
thank you further discussion
representative platt
an answer
i can't answer because i'm not expert at
the cost of this of taking this stuff
apart
uh and and the value of the different uh
rare elements that are in the rare earth
elements that they're listed in the bill
that's something for experts to do but
it's something that needs to be tackled
representative accident
thank you mr chair i just go back to the
advertisement these
there are lots and lots of very valuable
things in these panels and there are
businesses who it is their business
model to reclaim them in a sustainable
way
it is profitable and responsible to do
that we don't need to step in with the
state we don't need to step in with
mandates
uh thank you representative oxenam
one would assume that a stewardship plan
would certainly include that kind of uh
activity it seems like like at this
point that we're going around and around
and making the same arguments over and
over and we are nearing the end of our
allocated time so i would like to call
the question and have uh
representative callie pitts have the
final word before we do that
it's not the final word i i think
everybody knows how i feel i just had a
real question
when a panel is removed from a roof
does that panel have to be removed by a
person who is licensed
i i don't know
if there's damage on that roof
and wouldn't it be the person
who takes that panel off
who might be responsible for what to do
with it
i
have never seen a panel in action but i
know that they're connected to the
electricity system so do we have to have
someone
who is responsible and licensed to that
and then wouldn't it be more appropriate
for that person who is removing that
panel
to take care of it i don't know if many
people just rip them down themselves
thank you
representative platt
imagine there's all sorts of scenarios
out there and generally an electrician
is required to fool around with
electricity but for a homeowner that's
not necessarily so they can go do that
uh the point is is there'll be funds
available to recycle these properly
uh at the end of en end of life and if
if the homeowner is damaged to his or
her roof
she or he does damage to the roof but
hopefully somebody responsible will take
that down and knowing the fund is there
they'll do the right thing
okay so having given representative
kelly pitts the last word on this
question i'm going to call the question
on the amendment
or the motion rather to adopt amendment
0940h and ask the clerk to call the roll
yes
representative thomas
representative harrington yes
representative notter yes representative
mirner
is not here
if i had a chance to mark these up in
advance let's see
i know but i gotta take care of this
first
representative plett says yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's yes
representative pleasure yes represent
white yes represent the wiki yes
represent
is not here
represent cali pitts
no
representative man
no representative oxenoum no
representative vincent is not here
representative mcgee
no
representative schultz
representative christian not here
representative pimentel
representative uh partial help and the
chair
yes
one
two three four five six seven i agree
with the seven let's see
huh
four
11 7 4.
okay by a
vote of 11 yay and 7 nay the amendment
is adopted and the chair recognizes his
representative pled for a motion okay
mr chair i move to adopt
uh
house bill 1459 fn
as amended
representative nader is recognized
the second the motion it's moved and
seconded that we adopt house bill 1459
fn as amended by amendment 0940h
i'd ask the clerk to call the role on
the question
they had to get the right roll call
okay uh rep representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representing otter
yes representative mirner is not here
representative plett votes yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbells yes
representative pelosi yes
representative white yes
representative lewicki yes prep
sampsitch is not here
cali pitts
rep as a man
no representative oxendine no
representative vincent is not here
represent mcgee no
representative schultz no
representative creation is not here
represents pimentel
uh representative partial no
and the chair
yes
eleven
to seven to four
by a vote of eleven years and seven days
the motion to adopt house bill 1459 fn
as amended
passes
so
we will now
before we close the executive session i
will point out that representative
pimentel has already written the
minority report it's an excellent report
and representative platt will write the
majority report and with that
we close the public hearing on house
bill
1459 and we will take a very brief
three minute bio break
before we move on to our presentation
from eversource
so be back here in your chairs in three
minutes please
mr chair so i'm not there's no other
votes going on today in this committee
correct that is correct the only order
of business
going forward is a presentation from
eversource
my time here was brief but i enjoyed it
thank you well we enjoyed having you
thank you for being here
thank you
okay folks uh let's
resume our activity
please take your seats
okay thank you everybody
and we would like to now welcome to
science technology and energy the
uh
arborist from
eversource and uh
where miss ms gamache will introduce him
to our committee thank you very briefly
with me is probably one of the um
most popular employees at eversource
because he's very passionate about what
he does bob allen manager of vegetation
management thanks
thank you mr allen
welcome the floor is yours thank you
thank you donna
that's about the best introduction i've
ever had except for the time i had to do
myself when the speaker wasn't there so
um
so thank you for having me um what i
wanted to do was talk a little bit about
eversource's vegetation management
program
and i've brought some handouts today for
you
but this powerpoint that i put together
gives us some background on what we do
with the program and maybe give you some
idea of some of the things we're up
against and some of the things that we
help out on in the state so
um if everybody's ready the first slide
is uh
it's the eversource franchise territory
so 13 220 square mile operational area
we have 40 000 miles of overhead line
across three states
500 communities
so
we're on about a four to five year cycle
across the three states so that means
we're doing 10 000 miles a year of
trimming
36 employees we just bumped that up
we're about 42 right now internal
and 475 contractor tree crews working
across
connecticut mass and new hampshire every
day
a forest cover so percent tree cover
state rank this is something that the
u.s forest service does every 10 years
or so and it goes back and forth between
new hampshire and maine as number one
i preferred new hampshire to be number
one so that's where they are in this
particular slide
connecticut's number five i mean
massachusetts number six not everybody
would think of that as being those
heavily forested areas but it's based on
an aerial photo
and it's the cover the percent of forest
cover
and then the wildland urban interface
rank is uh connecticut number one
massachusetts number two in new
hampshire number four and that speaks to
how close is uh forested area or natural
area to where people live that is a very
densely populated small
state and so there's where there is
forest that's very close to where
there's people living but massachusetts
same thing in new hampshire is number
four on that
so what we like to say is this means our
customers live amongst the trees
of those 10 000 miles we do every year
we believe there's 175 trees per mile
when we trim
and a mile for this
argument or statistic is uh
30 pole sections so if you were to go
down the street and count 30 pole
sections and general that's about a mile
sometimes it's 20 sometimes it's 40 but
we go with 30. so 175 trees on average
every mile a line we're trimming
so that gives you over 7 million trees
for maintenance each cycle
but the thing that
we all we've all experienced is an
outage caused by the weather in a tree
is there's three to four times that
number in the fall zone
so what's the fall zone it's a 50 foot
tree 40 feet from the wires that would
be considered in the fall zone
so that's 21 million trees on any given
day that could fall and hit our wires
so
when you uh
when you go through an outage please try
and remember me and trying to take care
of those 21 million trees so
um the mission uh so we i don't want to
bore you with too much stuff but what
we're trying to do is effectively plan
schedule and manage services
so that we can take care of the trees
that are going to affect our wires
and therefore affect our customers
we have best management practices for
our t and d line clearance and t is
transmission d is distribution
transmission is over hill and dale the
big lines
distribution will be the lines that come
from the substation down the roads and
then into your house
we develop customer relations practices
deploy multi-channel communication
community outreach to facilitate field
execution vegetation management
activities what that says is once in a
while we put a picture on facebook and
uh and tell you that we're doing a good
job
so
we hire arborists
everybody goes to school for trees that
we hire
some of them might be wildlife ecology
some might be environmental science but
we're hiring arborists so our tree
people are looking after the tree people
that are doing the work
so we're very proud of our
professionalism on that
and then lastly we have performance
metrics and those are called sadie and
safety we love acronyms in the utility
world and i'll get to explaining what
those are in a couple slides
so managing the business of vegetation
management and these are these circles
pretty much tell you what we're up
against every day and what we're trying
to manage every day so that's customer
satisfaction
if the customers are happy then the new
folks are probably not hearing from them
and that's a good thing
reliability usually people are happy
when the power is reliable
storm resiliency if the storms don't
knock us out for as long as they used to
before we had the projects the way we do
with a
good infrastructure building and a
really an aggressive tree program that
we didn't have prior to the 2008 ice
storm
compliance quality control cost con are
all things that i deal with every day
and
as do our arborist so
on the next slide it's the key
reliability metrics and
as i said safety and sadie so safety
if i break it down it's uh and i'm sorry
i didn't number these slides i should
have um make it easier when i'm zipping
through them but
safety is system average interruption
frequency index
i didn't learn anything about that in
tree school
and then number three trouble spots and
then sadie would be system average
interruption
duration index
so looking at the graphs uh the red was
the 2021 target
and
the blue was the 2020 the deep blue was
the 2021 actual so we didn't make our
goal last year
and that's unfortunate but we did have a
good year
the problem is
we're very much a continuous improvement
company
and
in 2019 we had our best year ever
for reliability some of that's climates
some of its storms not being as
bad some of it's our trimming program
but we improved by 40 over our previous
best year
so now when you put a goal two years
later you're not gonna it's not gonna be
easy to get that goal
so
vegetation impact on reliability are
tree related outages so forty five
percent of outages on distribution are
due to vegetation across three states
that's twenty thousand outages a year
and ninety percent of outages during
storms are due to trees
but looking at this tree related safety
on this particular bar graph it shows
that our target was the blue line
and from 2016 on and that's when we
really started investing in
our strategy of taking down hazard trees
we've really improved our target and
again 2019 stands out as the best year
ever so
that speaks the amount of trees in the
fall zone
that we hadn't been looking to get in
the past and now we're looking deep for
trees
we have key internal partners obviously
veg we work with everybody
anybody that's doing line work
substations engineering when they're
going to build a new line or trying to
improve a line construction projects
tree
folks
are usually the first ones in and
oftentimes one of the last ones out
corporate relations certainly regulatory
affairs and community relations media
relations corporate communications my
good good friend donna gamache and uh
customer care supply chain environmental
affairs
so i put this little blurb in there
about millions of connecticut trees have
been killed or damaged in recent years
taking them down is expensive
so there's i've worked in connecticut
and in mass and up in new hampshire i've
been here 13 years working in this job
i've been with the company for 35 years
and connecticut and massachusetts have
different rules as far as the the way
the roads are laid out and i'm probably
gonna
be over generalistic here but in
connecticut and mass most
roads are three rod roads a rod would be
16 and a half feet and a kind of an
ancient
measurement so three rod road would be
sixteen and a half times three forty
nine and a half feet let's say fifty
feet
and that's in new hampshire too a lot of
them are three rod roads however in
connecticut and massachusetts about
ninety percent of the time
those roads are owned by the town
or the city
in new hampshire it's almost a direct
opposite we don't have as many roads
that are owned that way so
in that three rods in connecticut
massachusetts there's 25 to 30 feet of
traveled way 10 feet on either side
for a snow shelf sidewalk tree belt
whatever you want to call it
those trees in there are owned by the
town
and therefore they have a tree warden in
each town in connecticut and
massachusetts
in new hampshire we don't have that
situation more often than not if if i
lived across from the chairman
you would own 25 feet to the side of the
road and i would own 25 feet to the side
of the road and the town would have an
easement over our property and those
trees would actually be mine and yours
so so it's a little bit different when
we look at that but the reason i put
this in there is
what happened down there was uh the
drought we had a horrible drought in
2016 2017
they have emerald ash borer which has
now been in
new hampshire for a few years in the
whole states and
it's not a quarantine anymore the whole
state's got it every county
they had gypsy moth which i just found
out last week is not the correct
term anymore it's now called spongy moth
because gypsy is not politically correct
so um which is fine i just
40 years in this business i got to start
calling a bug sponge you know
i know then we'll have trouble
so um so the spongy moth the emerald ash
borer and the drought contributed to
thousands of trees that died in
connecticut
and
eversource doesn't own any trees as i
stated the trees that are owned they're
owned by either the town or the
property owner
so we worked really hard to try and work
with the states and the towns to work
together and take these trees down so
oftentimes we're working on one side of
the road where the wires are but there's
dead trees on the other side too
and they can fall over and hit us and
so we we've tried to partner with the
state and the town whenever possible
some towns are easier to partner with
than others some states are easier to
partner with those i've always been very
successful up here partnering with new
hampshire and it's the reason i'm here i
like it and
but i want you to know that that's
something that's going on emerald ash
borer is a big problem in new hampshire
it's gotten worse
every year
if you listen to kyle lombard who's the
state forest health insect specialist he
says um that 30 of the urban forest is
ash in new hampshire
six percent of the forest is ash but
um so we've got a lot of trees out there
by the roads that are failing quick
question for you does that ash borer
kill the trees
yes it does okay so it
what it does
is um
it bores in it's a flathead bore so it
comes out with a
like a half moon looking shaped hole
when it comes out it's not a round hole
so it comes out and it
it's young live inside the galleries
that it's developed and that stops the
phloem from going up so similarly like
the dutch elm disease was a vascular
disease animal dashboard can do the same
problem can cause the same problem so
trees die within two to three years you
notice it by something called blonding
and maybe you guys have seen this
but woodpeckers go after
the bugs that are inside and they go
pretty much in a straight line and
you'll see the bark turn from gray to
yellowish so if you see blonding on an
ash you know you've got emerald ash
borer
because the woodpeckers are pretty smart
when it comes to food
so
again i don't know
i know some pockets of areas in the
state where there's problems with it
already but i think it's going to grow
into a bigger a bigger problem yeah if i
may uh so so you notice you have one
tree that's got the blonde
do you call someone to get rid of it or
do you just let it
grow a good question so
you want to get rid of it if you can
what we used to have to do was chip it
and either leave it right there or take
it to a spot where you could only it
couldn't cross county lines now but the
every county has it so it's not as much
of an issue
i'd hate to say this but the ashes are
going to be difficult to save as a
species
with this particular bug
there's certainly ones you can say this
one is really important to us we want to
save it and we're going to pay to do
whatever nests yes
or not um
the pine bore out west yes
it's a similar situation yes but i know
i understand that the pine bore it's a
reproductive life
used to be that's one season one mating
yeah and now with the extended uh
summers it's once uh one summer two
matings yeah twice as many insects
is your emerald ash borer or a similar
situation as far as you're aware that's
a great question as far as i know not
yet
it potentially could be but i think it
uh they overwinter as eggs or larvae in
in the tree and then they come out so i
think they have to over winter for one
year
but i'm not sure of that i'll look that
up
yep
any other insect bug questions yeah
if you said if you chip one of the
affected trees yeah the does the larvae
and the eggs still stay on the on the on
the floor and they go to other trees
they can't leave really so you chip it
into one pile and they just are staying
there probably not gonna live okay
that's the thought process but okay
yes
go ahead fred
is there uh
any predator uh any uh controlling
another bug that would control the first
one yeah so there's there's always
natural predators for these types of
things we haven't been able to release
anything yet on emerald ash borer that
has made a difference
there are other things such as purple
loosestrife which is a invasive species
that we've seen in the state for years
and the state of zx doug saigan from
invasive species has actually released a
bug that will eat that
so it's it's
we've done a good job of controlling
that that way but
it's hard to find a predator for every
bug
because there's always something else
that's easier to eat than a bug that's
inside a tree so
representing ricky thank you mr chairman
um what about resistant strains of the
actual tree because my neighborhood
they've all been gotten except one that
i planted about 30 years ago and it
seems to be doing okay that's fantastic
i maybe can market that one
no it's always something that you see
that there's some natural resistance
there's still elm trees around even
though dutch elm swept through this
country over the last eight decades
there's still occasional elm trees that
you see so
but i don't know of any strain that's
necessarily a species or a cultivar
that's been come up with yet on the
market that is ash that's resistant
yep
representative partial
i could add to that question knowing
that um in my nearby city of king
there is a
farm who specializes in uh resistant
dutch elm uh seedlings and you can buy a
dutch elm ceiling from them
um but it's a matter of a number of
years to be forest uh yep situation yeah
the elm research institute in keene was
uh was one of the groups that was doing
it for years and also chestnuts they're
trying to
come that that's come back a long ways
but
we lose these species because of really
because of global
commerce i think we bring more bugs in
so
um all right let me go back to this it's
a little more boring than what we were
just talking about but uh
so this uh this talks about our
regulatory programs and basically what i
said was it's four to five years
in massachusetts four to five years in
new hampshire and then four years in
connecticut
and the hardest thing to get that work
done
is there's nobody new coming into this
business
this is not a well-paid
it's not even a profession in a lot of
people's minds being a tree guy
and we've fought this for 40 years i've
been involved in it it's it the pay just
isn't there and we find it harder and
harder to get people in i went to
stockbridge school of agriculture in
umass
graduated in 1982 there were 62 people
in my major of arbor culture
this year there's four
so
it's thompson school went through a
similar situation so it's it's just
difficult
everybody
you know wants to have an easier job you
got to work outside 12 months a year and
with a chainsaw usually a loft and
so
but if you're passionate about it or you
like it or you want to be outside you
don't want somebody yelling at you or if
they yell at you you can just rub the
chainsaw a little more they don't have
to hear them
so our distribution programs as i said
we love acronyms so smt is scheduled
maintenance trimming and that's what we
do every day that's our program where we
trim
10 000 miles a year across eversource
and in new hampshire that's going to be
around 2 600 miles this year
enhanced tree trimming which is along
our backbone lines which have the most
customers affected
those lines are cut and cleared at a
greater expanse
reliability tree work is something we
came up with in massachusetts we don't
do it in new hampshire yet
regular tree removal we're looking for
hazard and risk trees
right away maintenance again we're going
over hill and dale and we're mowing
and and climbing trees in that area
mid-cycle is usually for us it's usually
vines
that bother us between the cycles and
again we have the vine program also yes
yes go ahead fred
having been a former employee
a hundred years ago
uh i do know that most of your
distribution
a lot of your distribution is 34 and a
half kv yes uh as opposed to massive
other states around us it might be 12 or
even 4kv which means is that does that
mean more of it is subject to enhanced
tree trimming you've got more customers
on a line
and uh more
chance for interruption because there's
more customers on the line so that
higher voltage whether it's the 34 5 or
23 but you're right most states around
us do not have 345 on the roadside
but
it's from our backbone is considered
from the source usually the substation
down to the first operating device which
could be a fuse or a re-closure or
something so any customers in that area
is where we're getting the higher
clearance zone because we can impact so
many more people
if we lose the line there that's going
to be a big outage so
a good question
cali pits
i'm not a tree expert at all i like
trees is the shade
and the fruit they bear
but
i what concerns me is you are an
arborist and you say there's not many
coming
but the contractors that are hired by
the company
are just
i don't know how to say it choppers
and
that's is that where some of the
controversy comes in that
as p have you looked at every place that
needs to be trimmed or has somebody
of your caliber looked at every place
that needs to be trimmed and then you
rely on your contractors to
follow
your directives and that doesn't always
happen
so yeah i think like any profession
there's always going to be a day where
somebody's not having their best day so
that can happen but
the contractors bid on our work we give
them the specifications it's and then
this
led right into the next slide which is
great um
so it's our distribution programs which
show uh eight feet to the side of the
wires 10 feet below the wires and 15
feet above the wires and
and our our wires are always at the top
of the pole electric wires are always on
the top
uh phone wires are always on the bottom
and then could be cable or a fire or
something in between but we're always on
the top
so
we do 100 quality control audits if the
work was trimmed this year we're out
there looking at it and we have
well it'll be march 31st everything has
to be looked at from 2021 by march 31st
is the way we do it so you can't
obviously if you're trimming on december
20th you're not going to be able to get
out there and look at it if you're
looking at stuff from november's
trimming so we give ourselves a couple
months to take care of it and then we
send the contractor back
to fix anything that we find we call it
a go back
anything that hits the go back list or
the punch list as we might call it also
is something that's done on their nickel
we don't pay for it they have to go back
and do it
and
these specifications uh as i oftentimes
tell the guys haven't changed since 1986
a lot of the tremors were born since
then so they've only known this
specification but it seems like
sometimes they struggle with it so yeah
we're
it's a profession and or it's a craft
that they're trying to learn and some
guys
um have have tougher days than other
guys some guys are better at it than
other guys so
um
but we look at 100 of everything so if
there's a problem and we haven't heard
about it from our customers we'll find
it when we're out there inspecting stuff
our ett excuse me is enhanced tree
trimming
and that is required to get permission
from the landowner
and
oftentimes people want their trees down
and they want the free firewood they
want
lose the risk of the tree coming down
they've been dealing with the leaves or
the acorns or they're dropping something
every day
and if they're on a backbone line as i
said we're looking to take those trees
down
if they're a hazard to us
oftentimes they're hazard because of
their
species because of their proximity
because of the soil they're growing in
or other issues that might have happened
to them
but we're looking at for ett we do about
50 miles a year out of those 2 500.
the next slide we have tree removals
this is over 50 000 trees removed
annually that's across three states
but you can see some of those trees we
have marked on the left-hand system
our left-hand side
have ribbons on them we generally use
blue and white ribbons now
they're checkered
and the reason we've done that is
because
lots of people put if we were using
orange they'll put orange on theirs and
hope that we're going to take it down
so
so blue and white is not as easy to find
and it's expensive so we we use are more
expensive than the other stuff so we use
that now
so quick question yes what happens to 50
000 trees is a lot of trees what happens
to all the
the wood is it chipped is it
how do you deal with it so a lot of
times we have people trying to get their
pickup truck right underneath it before
we take it down uh and we usually don't
have any problem getting rid of the wood
even now with we used to have problems
with white pine
because not not anybody want to burn
that but now with the wood boilers those
folks will burn anything
maple producers they don't mind it
usually they have their own sources but
if we're nearby they'll take some wood
from us
some of it goes we can't sell it and we
don't have any interest in selling it we
want it to be given away or have
somebody use it we have explored
um what's known as wood banks
and we've delivered wood to wood banks
and there's one in the antrum a few
years ago we didn't it used to be a
thing in connecticut where they were
taking homeless men taking them off the
street
at a thing called open hearth and they
were
giving them a chance to
become part of society again by cutting
and splitting wood and then delivering
it and selling it so we were donating
wood to the open hearth
and they were there's a big program they
had to manage the whole thing and give
these folks places to stay and feed them
but they earned money and they became
part of the society again um
we've never really found a way to do
that in any other state it's it's a it's
a big undertaking and in new hampshire
where a lot of people burn wood and i i
mean i burn seven or eight cords a year
and i buy it i don't get it for free
but um
there's always somebody who wants the
wood and as far as the chips
our chips are very popular
with
folks that have berry bushes blueberries
especially
christmas tree farms like them and one
of the things that's happened in my 40
years of doing this is
people have started to go away from the
wanting the black mulch or the red mulch
or the it's got dye in it they want
natural stuff it's really native
oriented now so
our chips are becoming more popular even
though they're not landscape quality and
they might be a little
messy at times there might be some twigs
in there or something but it's better
because it's the organic matter is going
right back into the soil so we're
finding more outlets for that
it's a great question though
distribution programs are right away
maintenance and if i'm taking too long
please let me know i'm happy to stay
here all day but um
so we're not using herbicide in new
hampshire
um
the other utilities do we haven't uh for
going on three or four decades now so we
just mow
with what's known as a brontosaurus
by john brown company out of goffstown
they they created the machine and most
of our contractors use it
mowing is a benign term when it comes to
what they're doing out there but it's uh
it clears it
um
the sheep so the sheep
the sheep was a great idea um it was
so it was par
let me if i can take a minute when i
came up here it had
been closed off uh i don't know maybe it
was in the 90s they did that donna
yeah it was early
and it was it was a partnership with us
in unh to get your goat
to find out if it was um it was viable
fiscally responsible certainly it seemed
like it was responsible to take care of
the right-of-ways that way but well it
was fiscally responsible to do it that
way and um
three years of study and it proved to
not be
at all because the the sheep
um wanted to eat
forbs and weeds and grasses not stuff
that was ever going to come up into the
power line
i've been trying to work with a cross
between a sheep and a beaver and if i
can ever get that
we'll be able to put that out there but
you mentioned goats and goats are being
used for poison ivy control in boston in
the city parks and it's it's worked out
really well
um but again the stuff grows back and
and with the sheep
with us it just wasn't fast enough they
kept going back to the same area they
wouldn't move that far down the road so
but one of the coolest things when i
when i did one of our guys steve johnson
retired
and they sent over to me his vegetation
management files and the official top
secret name of that was
operation lamb chop
so i thought that was kind of cool
emergent work so that's the type of work
we don't have planned capital
construction when somebody comes in
wants to develop a new area customer
requests municipal partnering as i
mentioned some of those trees that we
take down are partnering with towns and
state and then outage investigations
so our outage investigations are
something we do and across three states
in 2020 this is from we did 110 outage
investigations
this is outages caused by trees that
knocked power out to over 100 customers
so our arbors go out there they look at
the area they decide what the tree
uh caused where it came from
and were there any other issues there
that we don't want the customers to
expect who have another outage just
because there's a bad tree in the same
zone so
what we found were 77 from outside the
clearance zone 60 from outside zone are
three failures
37 percent were limb breaks
23 from inside the clearance zone 50
percent were limb brakes and 42 percent
of tree failures
so one of the reasons we have them
inside the zone is we don't have a truck
that goes up high enough we have 70 foot
booms but we really can't get much
higher than that so when we try and get
ground to sky clearance on our ett it's
limited by whatever equipment we have
representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman thank you mr allen
for this lovely presentation
um this just made me think of uh we came
for a visit at eversource and we took a
look at the technology that allows folks
to isolate you know the outages on the
line and i'm just curious how much that
technology informs the work that you do
because it seems to me when i look at
this you know outage investigation piece
that you may have people
who from that software would be able to
say oh i know where that i mean is it
down to that kind of level it absolutely
is and we're working towards that where
we're going to start to look at
i never want to predict against mother
nature but we're going to try and figure
out where we're having issues and and
talking about kyle lombard from the
state we got his heat map on
where the insect issues are in a state
we're overlaying that on our circuit map
so we can see where we're going to trim
next and figure out where there might be
issues we're also taking weather data
that's great from uconn it's it's that's
exactly what i was thinking it's like
wow if you can do that heat map
signature and figure out where the trees
are weak
that's that's terrific for you i just
wish you had more people and i wish we
could figure out some way to help
it be a better paid profession because
that's true of a lot of the really most
essential professions is that they just
don't they don't incent enough people to
to come into the profession yep and i
think one of the issues is osha
considers trees as part of waste
management so a tree worker is not even
a profession in osha we do have our own
regulations but
it's never been classified as a high
enough profession so
um
next one this is usually
important to a lot of people this is the
service wire the line that comes into
your house
we don't maintain that as part of our
program work and neither do any of the
new england utilities there was a time
when we did
um i remember having a pole saw in the
back of my chevy chevette when i first
got hired in 1987
and i would trim services for folks
but we will prune service if there's a
hard contact so if that wire should be
going like this and a branch makes it go
like this or go like that we'll trim
that
we don't do removals for service wires
but in new hampshire and western mass
the company customer can arrange for the
company to drop the service wire so
we'll come out with knock it we'll take
it off the pole take it off your house
you take your tree down we put it back
up no charge
um connecticut and eastern mass they're
a little bit different they want their
money for doing something like that but
but we're working on changing that yes
because that's got something to do with
ownership because in new hampshire
psnh
the company owns the service drop
whereas other states the customer owns
the service drop there are certain
situations like that where it changes
throughout the state yep
um but we
we don't have enough outages on services
to make it worthwhile for us to spend
that kind of money that would take to
maintain all the services so we look at
everyone if you call in and there you
constituent calls in we go out and look
at it and frankly if they've got a good
story we'll probably do it but um
it's uh it's not something we do as a
profes as a part of the program
um emergency response so as i said we're
we're a major part of any storm and
we've had a lot of storms over the last
few years
um one of the things that's difficult
for us and it's a it's a positive
is that these storms
that would have knocked us out for a
week or two weeks in the past due to the
tree trimming we've done due to the
enhancements to our system as you
mentioned
they're not taking as much time to get
them back in which is great for our
customers it makes the storms not as
recoverable for us so we bring in a lot
of crews
to make sure we're not out of power for
a long time and then it it becomes a an
issue trying to fight to
to get some of that back but that's not
for today i just want to let you know
that we've noticed there's more and more
storms that we've been very good at
storm that's when we shine and
i can't remember the last time i think
that the ice storm in 2008 was the last
time we're out for
over a week
so
vegetation management safety commitment
so every year we have an annual safety
summit the last two years obviously have
been remote
but what we do is we bring all the
contractors in usually their
safety people and their leadership
and we talk about what we can do to
improve the safety of everybody that's
out there
when i first started we never talked
contractors never talked to each other
if somebody had an accident you'd go all
those guys they don't know what they're
doing they had an accident now it's so
transparent everybody's trying to help
each other and we make sure if and this
is a bad thing i guess somebody has the
biggest accident of the year the next
year they have to present on it in front
of everybody which gives us lessons
learned after action review it it's
better for everyone and this i'm very
proud of the fact that we do this we
only started doing this about five or
six years ago and it's it's excellent
customer municipal contact
so every year we contact over three
hundred thousand customers across the
three states
less than one percent of property owners
do not allow the work to take place
so we we track that
we also know where those out where those
refusals are i don't have a whole lot of
them in new hampshire and the law that
was changed in september in
september 2009 uh which was went from a
permission state to a
opt-out notification state
has really helped an awful lot and
still gives people a chance to talk
about it to meet with us they have 45
days to talk to us it's a great law
but connecticut doesn't have that same
situation they've got the most draconian
and
stuff going on down there they've got
about five different ways you can
contact a customer that has another
the customer can change the
specifications and so it's they've run
into a lot of problems down there and i
don't have any problem with customers
saying this is what i want done to my
tree that's how they should be it's
their tree
but
it's become a lot more difficult to work
down there than it is here and in
massachusetts so
um this next thing is the mailer this is
what we send out to all our customers
and i think i brought some today i have
a bunch of handouts for you
but this is gives people a chance to
read it what's going to happen
they tear it's they tear a piece off and
and they send it back to us and they can
say i want a consultation i don't want
you to trim or everything's okay
i thought we might need some levity so i
put imagine if trees gave off wi-fi
signals we'd be planting so many trees
we'd probably save the planet too bad
they only produce the oxygen we breathe
so
um
yes
go ahead
representative callie fitz jackie's fine
on the uh oxygen
believe it or not i
does
your group in the company or does the
company sponsor any
replanting programs so that people who
have had their
trees cut
um
either know what they can plant so they
won't have to go through that again and
maybe
is there any incentive for people to
plant again sure
i think i might take you to every
presentation because you're fitting
right in with what i want to talk about
so this is this is great now yes we
don't have a one for one tree
replacement program but we'll talk to
you about certainly what should be
planted there and you'll see from some
of our handouts that it's a very
important part of what we do
so this is hardiness zones this tells
you what plants can grow where so
obviously we don't have palm trees in
florida and we don't have white pine
trees and or we don't have palm trees in
new hampshire we don't have white pine
trees in florida
but all four of these hardiness zones
occur in new hampshire i think it's the
only
might be the only new hampshire or new
england state that has all four
so that tells you what kind of trees we
can deal with representative thomas has
a question oh thank you uh ju real quick
going back you're talking about
my good friend from portsmouth brought
up a
replanting thing
could you
just as an example i i i know there was
an issue that happened during the
merrimack valley reliability project
where a particular house hold in my
district
was particularly hit hard and i believe
they either helped or they actually
replanted trees and vegetation if you
are aware of that example could you
describe very quickly what the process
was involved with that sure
i'm not aware of that particular
instance but in general if we're doing a
major line like that if we come to your
property and we say we're going to
change the way it looks we added these
trees out those trees out those shrubs
we will come back and talk about a
planting plan so that everybody knows
what's going to happen what's coming out
and then what's going to go back in and
those are generally just on these big
projects when we're coming to your house
to take down a tree
if it's one you really don't want to
come down even if it's in bad shape
and we want it down there might be a
negotiation where we could replant the
tree for you but as i said we don't have
a one for one that would be
very difficult to achieve for us as far
as the budget goes
but that particular situation on a
project we always do that if we're going
to affect your property we come and talk
to you about how that's going to look
and what it will look like in the future
and and do they do the planning or is
that up to the customer to
the owner
generally we would do the planting or
one of our contractors were there have
been situations where we just drop off
plants because that's what the customer
wants they either don't want to deal
with us that way they don't want us on
their property that way they just want
the plants
so we'll do that but we also have
people who are very good at design and
can
from a couple of our different
contractors and we have great
relationships with our nurseries we deal
mostly with milliken which is a
wholesale nursery in chichester
but most of the trees we try and plant
in new hampshire are grown in new
hampshire so thank you yep
um
tall growing native species so these
trees
um all
at maturity can reach 50 feet or more
and they're all native trees mostly
native trees in our area but our poles
are usually 40 to 50 feet tall
so
as i said i've been doing this for 40
years and i've never seen anything fall
up so newton's law is still in effect so
if
the trees are tall and our poles are
going to come down and if we're in the
way we're going to have an outage so
uh
and i'll talk a little bit further about
smaller growing trees here in a minute
but acorns um there's always a lot of
acorns oaks are a tremendous food source
for our
uh squirrels and turkeys and and deer
and
um
four of these species here are you'll
find in new hampshire the fifth one over
cup
uh probably only if you go to my house
you'll find that one but
mad horse
i'm going to try and do a little
backyard botany here and i hope you guys
don't mind so
for trees that drop their leaves
deciduous trees
there's only two types of branching
structure
and if that diagram on the left will
show you it's either opposite so
wherever there's one branch there's one
directly opposite
or alternate there's one here there's
one here there's one here
those are the only two ways that
deciduous trees grow
so mad horse is an acronym
maple
ash
dog dogwood and horse chestnut are the
only trees
that grow
alternate or they grow opposite
alternate is everything else elm hickory
birch beech apple
cherry they're all alternate but mad
horses opposite branching trees so what
does that help you with well in the
winter when we don't have leaves on the
trees
it can help us talk to a customer who
wants to know what what type of tree it
is or help our guys know this tree is
going to grow this fast or that fast
because it's this type of tree it helps
them a little bit
and then to the right we have
what's known as a compound leaf so that
would be your nut trees your hickories
and walnuts
are the first ones i think of with
compound leaves but that whole thing
that hole is a is a leaf
and those are all leaflets
so those are opposite those leaflets but
that's not part of it the leaf itself is
actually
alternate so
um
there's two types of
all of uh compound leaves there's pin8
which i'm showing in this which is like
a feather is pinnate and palmate would
be like your hand and that's how a horse
chestnut or a buckeye grows so there's
five leaves coming out just like your
hand
there's also a couple tricks for spruce
fur and hemlock
so when you think about
christmas trees seasonal trees december
trees however you want to call it
they
tend to be pyramidal
and our native white pine is not
necessarily that shape it's a tall
growing tree with a big trunk but the
ones that are pyramidal are usually
spruce and fur sometimes hemlock
so a spruce tree
the cones hang down
and a fir tree the cones go up
so if you're driving by
a bunch of trees and you go i wonder
what those are they look like spruce and
then you see the cones are going up it's
a fir tree and
it took me about 20 years to figure that
out
but
hemlock the cones are always going to be
on the end of the branches as i show on
that bottom right
so it's just a also another way to tell
is if you put your hand open hand on the
needles of a spruce tree you're going to
feel it it's going to be prickly if you
do it on a fir tree it's going to be
very soft
so
i put this in just because we've
experienced this pandemic for the last
couple years and a lot of people did
stay home so perhaps the most radical
thing we can do is stay at home so we
can learn the names of the plants and
animals around us so we can begin to
know what the tradition is we're part of
one of the things that happened with the
pandemic is there were more plant sales
at nurseries than ever before
and it's harder to get plants of any
size it's hard to get a lot of landscape
material which is a tremendous thing
that more people are getting involved in
planting and taking care of their stuff
but it's harder for us when we go to
plant the trees there's just not as much
stock available to us
so you've always heard that thing be
careful what you wish for or what you
asked for
i asked one of our admins to find the
picture on the internet that looked like
me
and
so
so that's hillbilly jim he was a
wrestler and he's now i think he's a
disc jockey in
outlaw country but uh anyhow he's
smiling and i'm usually smiling so
that's good
um so the two most commonly asked
questions why do oaks hold on to their
leaves and why are there so many acorns
this year and
i'm going to answer sure so that so the
next one is the next slide is why do
oaks hold their leaves
so they're marcescent and what that
means is that they um they hold on to
their leaves that's basically all that
means they're part of fagaci
fugacie which is the beach family oaks
are part of the beach family so beach
will hold their leaves too
so the there's a book that came out last
year by dr doug tallamy called the
nature of oaks he's a professor down in
uh maryland
he's written a lot of plant plant books
a lot of native books and he's an he's
an entomologist by trade but he's really
become a
hero in the native plant
movement
and he says there's three reasons that
oaks hold on to their leaves now oaks
and beach were also southern plants long
before
our forefathers ever thought about this
country they were
but as things have changed they've come
north
so the first thing he says is dinosaur
browse
so as the dinosaurs went to eat the
leaves
the tree as a defense mechanism left its
leaves on so they would not be as tasty
and if you look at
oak trees oftentimes the top is bare but
the bottom third has leaves on it and
his feeling was that that was the height
of which the dinosaurs would do it no
i don't know anybody that was a witness
to that so i can't say it was right or
wrong
but it makes sense to me
the next thing is snow retention so as
the snow comes down through the trees if
it lands on leaves that are still there
when it melts it goes right into the
root system so again instead of blowing
all over the place it's possibly another
defense or or just evolution of the
plant to try and make things better for
it and then lastly spring nutrients
when those leaves do finally come off as
the new leaf comes out it pushes the
opposition layer to drop the leaf
it lands right below the tree
and it goes right into for fertilization
and nitrogen no it doesn't it lands on
my driveway or my
lawn i have five giant oak trees on my
property and i spend
a quarter of the year moving oak leaves
oh it drives me crazy
oak dry oak drops something every day of
the year there's never a year a day it
goes by that doesn't drop something
so
so those that's the answer for why they
hold their leaves according to dr
ptolemy and i've been doing this a long
time and i think it's probably as close
to the truth as any other
um i don't know if i'm supposed to
got a couple people raising their hands
there's your microphone rod please
is bittersweet an issue for your power
lines it's an issue for the poles so
oriental beaters bittersweet is the
invasive species there is an american
bittersweet that doesn't really cause
much problem but the oriental is a very
fast growing plant grows up the poles
gets into the transformer and can cause
an outage
my guys the tree contractors can only
cut it when it's below
the
wire zone if you will
so going around every four or five years
to do our trimming
this thing is a very aggressive grower
so it does become a problem
we do this mid-cycle program every two
years to look for it
but that's the biggest problem we have
with vines is oriental bittersweet
john okay thank you mr chairman um this
while we're on the subject uh i think it
was two years ago we had massive numbers
of white pine cones
and stink bugs and do you have any
explanation for that
so the pine cones i can talk a little
bit about but the stink bugs
yeah yeah so
um
i think that's just a cyclical insect
like a lot of them are um but i don't
know that that was a specific year for
them um but where do you live
oh okay
well i'm in new york new orleans so not
too far away so i'll have to take a look
but i don't recall anything like that
getting calls about that particular bug
oh i'm sure it's not it's just that you
know stuff that we don't and this was an
opportunity oh thank you um
that's kind of you so uh the cones and
the and the acorns what we call a mast
ear
so a mast year is um
if you read these bullets the fruits
nuts berries buds and so on produced by
trees and bushes are called mast
hard mast includes walnuts pecans
hickory nuts hard seeds and acorns soft
masks includes berries fruits buds and
even rose hips but we include pine cones
in that as far as hard mask
so why do we have the mast year every
few years um
this takes a little bit of a leap but
the trees do talk to each other
and there's been a lot of books that
come out about that in the last few
years
finding the mother tree was on the best
of the list for a long time by suzanne
smart and there's a lot of that stuff in
there the secret life of trees all this
talks about how the
the roots are intertwined and they send
signals to each other if there's a bug
affecting one or if it's dying it might
send out some nutrients and hopefully
goes out into the community
i i believe it i i'm not a scientist i
believe it it seems to make sense to me
because i know the root zone is a very
important zone so
um why do we have a mast year
the trees signal to each other
that they need to put out more fruit in
any given year the reason being is that
mother nature will always adjust
so
if they put out the same amount of
acorns every single year
then the squirrels the deer the turkey
the blue jays which is a big
blue jays are a big acorn eater feeder
which i didn't know
um
they will create enough young to eat all
the acorns so if it's always a hundred
acorns from this tree they'll create
enough young to delete those hundred
acorns so mother nature says well
sometimes we have to just send out a
thousand acorns where we used to send
out a hundred
and that ensures that after everything
gets eaten
they'll still be enough for regeneration
so something will grow up from those
seeds
additionally
the squirrels maybe say hey
mardi gras time so they have more kids
and then the next year we don't put out
as many acorns so then there's a
struggle between the young and the old
and maybe that gets that population back
under control
so it's a very interesting
scientific dynamic i wish i was an
expert in it because i think it's a
really cool thing but to me that's the
answer is that mother nature's saying we
need to make sure we can regenerate this
species
or we get a squirrel apocalypse like we
had right four or five years ago right
absolutely and that was based on the
last year
so
yeah
yep
that's amazing
i always tell you i think that
explanation is nuts
[Laughter]
jose
yes on the squirrel mageddon i you know
i've been in the state for a long time
i've never seen anything like that yeah
do you recall in your experience so i
don't and was it in fact the bad mask
here that year it was we had a couple of
last years in in the teens and um
because i had to explain it out at my
work about why there were so many cones
and i didn't have as much into info now
as i do for you folks but um
so squirrels are obviously proliferate
they're gonna they're gonna keep growing
and and um when the climate's right and
when there's other things right there's
not as many predators for them they'll
just keep continuing to get out of
control and mother nature finds a way
i don't know if it
was by vehicles but
but they did take care of it
so i do have squirrels on my tie today
too so
but blue jays blue jays can carry five
acorns in their gullet
i never would have thought that and they
tend to plant more oak trees than
squirrels do
so
um getting to the planting the right
tree in the right space the average
median house sizes increased by 62
percent over time
so in 1973 the average house in america
was 1660 square feet
2015 it was 2687 square feet
so what that means is it's taking up
more of the lot
and as it takes up more of the lot
there's less chance for large trees to
be there
now large trees are great i call them
noble trees there's always good to see
noble trees around it's new england
built on having large trees and our
foliage industry is usually from large
trees but
our trees can be reliable year after
year with fall color
but when it comes to power lines and
house size
smaller trees are better for us near the
power lines
so i included a thing that i found to be
the best thing i've ever read on
planting trees so this i won't go over
but
it's something you can look at if you're
ever going to plant the tree
one thing that i've been very proud of
at eversource is
after working here a long time and i've
been arguing as an arborist
that we needed to do something on
planting the right tree in the right
place
replanting trees when we can
looking at situations where if we're
going to trim these trees
every year wouldn't it be better if we
didn't have those trees there we had
trees that only grew up so tall and you
can't make it all be like a lego set
where you have this on one side and that
on the other but you can try and work
with it and when you take a tree down
that's too big maybe suggest putting a
smaller tree in so
i was able to build a
two pole two sections
um
utility arboretum over at the urban
forestry center in portsmouth
after they had a big windstorm about
2012 i think it was and they lost all
their spruce trees i was on the
community forest advisory council for
the state and i said what do we should
we do here
when we try utility arboretum so we put
two side two poles in with one line
dead planted trees that would grow near
the wires so instead of going on the
internet and looking at this little tree
and saying i want that you actually get
to go there 52 weeks a year if you want
and see how that tree grows and what it
looks like near the wires
so it was only 10 trees so we had a as
you know we used to be public service
new hampshire and part of northeast
utilities we combined with and star
became eversource my boss at the time
vera admore sachi didn't know much about
trees but she was the best boss i ever
had she knew what she knew and she knew
it didn't what she didn't know and she
she gave us the the chance to show her
what we did what she didn't know and and
try and learn and try and help us and
she was just fantastic a very humane
person
and we had a all hands meeting at the
portsmouth urban forestry center
and i was supervisor in new hampshire at
that time and she said i love this i
want you to do it in connecticut
massachusetts and i said well
i only cover new hampshire i don't see
how i'm going to get that done she said
you'll figure it out
and to her credit um
she then gave me massachusetts to deal
with for for five years and i got one
built down at umass
and we built one at hooksett two years
ago
uh which representative plett came and
went on a tour with us last year
um
but what it is is
we have four of them now three of them
are de-energized lines so we can have
safety days there we can have training
days there people can bring their bucket
trucks in and teach guys how to work
near the wires without having a problem
um the one in hooksett is a live line
but that's where my office is and i
decided i just i want to take advantage
of being here every day and we planted
we got over 60 trees there so what we've
done
is try and put species that only grow
30 feet tall
as i said our polls are 40 to 50 feet
tall and
we've also brought some species up from
the mid-atlantic states
to see if there is a climate change
issue if there isn't i don't know but
we'll try them here and see how they do
we put something called a crepe myrtle
which people have maybe seen if they've
gone down south
at the umass one it grows up every year
it dies every winter goes down comes
back the next spring goes up we never
thought it would do that
so
the research has been good there we have
something called a
chinese fringe tree
at our hooksett site and there is a
there's a um
native fringe tree which some people
call old man's beard it's got hanging
white flowers in the spring it's more of
a shrub but the chinese fringe tree is
supposed to be zone six and that's not
supposed to be in new hampshire but it's
here and it's doing all right so
that type of thing it doesn't cost the
company really anything to try and do
this we're working with our contractors
they donated a lot of the time and the
effort
and the plants
to have this nice space so we'd love to
have you folks come down and do a tour
if you'd like to see it at some point
it's right down in hooksett on legends
drive and i'll be glad to host that
and show you what we've done
but as we continue to do this we
research and see if there's other plants
that will grow up in in new hampshire
which gives us a chance to get away from
having an ash species go away or an elm
species go away have i gone over time
well we're getting uh fairly close to
the end of our time
rod
another question for you concerning
choosing these different trees that
you're dealing with one of them you
mentioned was a chinese fringe tree
is that's not native it's not native and
are are there concerns about something
like that sure there's always an
invasive well it's not an invasive but
it's not native so the difference is
um
some plants are invasive that are not
natives
however
i've got a post here 30 under 30 33
zones with 30 feet tall i sent it out to
1200 garden centers and nurseries
it has japanese maple on it japanese
maple is one of the most highly planted
trees in the united states it's a very
nice ornamental little tree red leaves
green leaves
lots of people have it my feeling was if
i tell
the
landscapers and nursery industry that we
don't want you selling that anymore it's
really going to impact them economically
and so there are some native trees that
are on our utility arboretum there's
some non-native trees but there's
nothing that really hasn't been in the
trade for for decades we're not bringing
anything new when they say oh we've
never tried this before let's bring it
to the united states we're not doing
that
so
um and i'll zip through this so we have
four arboretum locations
uh
umass portsmouth hooksett and burling
connecticut
i put together this 30 under 30 which is
the poster i sent out and you folks have
a copy today
just shows you the trees that will
grow that we suggested plant near the
wires
next slide is of two books dr michael
durr who gave us the photos for that
poster
and that's great if you're looking at
landscape plants if you want to learn
what kind of trees you have near your
property
the field guide from audubon society is
a better better option
i put this in i hope you don't think
it's pandering to the audience but
dudley orr the first attorney general of
new hampshire had this quote
and i thought it was really an excellent
quote as you get older you don't sleep
as much
while i lie awake i think about what
good things i can do for people so one
of the things i think about is how can i
get people to plant the right tree in
the right place
and that's something we've really worked
on
and i'll finish with a much younger me
who was able to still climb trees saying
thank you
thank you that was a wonderful
presentation
[Applause]
thank you uh
i would encourage members if you have
further questions if mr allen can stay
for a few minutes you can speak with him
but i'm going to
call the official meeting to an end for
today and thank you mr allen and ms
gamash again for being here thank you mr
chairman and the whole committee i
appreciate being able to share this with
you thank you
that was outstanding
all right so we're done for the day
we'll see you all on thursday
uh in reps hall take care
you